hello welcome back to game sports
continuing coverage of e3 2014 you're
watching the game spot stage my name is
Daniel you are we swapped out the
American dude for the Irish dude I want
to keep on showing you sweet games load
stuff coming up h1z1 Phoenix rage
dubbers loads but right now i'm joined
by dave georgia ssin from SOE my friend
director of development and forever
quest EverQuest next I should say but
we're here to talk about landmark which
is a kind of a crazy project that's I
guess it's running before we get to play
everquest next but it's going to
continue on once it's once it's released
as well this is almost like some sort of
crowd funding for ideas for creating
your worlds hmm we're designing
EverQuest next we realized we were
making such crazy cool new design kind
of frontier stuff that we had to make
specialty tools and we thought well
wouldn't it be cool if we gave the tools
to the players ahead of time so they can
actually help us make the world and that
kind of snow balled and he kept getting
bigger and bigger and now landmark is
its own entertainment experience it's a
full-on MMO and growing every day but
it's also pioneering the systems that
will use in EverQuest next for the new
north and the players are collaborating
with us to determine what EverQuest next
is like at the same time that it's an
entertaining fun experience in the game
of its own so landmark is is a fair to
say that EverQuest next and much like GQ
will be a world that is has a relative
amount of persistence or what that world
is where buildings are and where cities
are and landmark is almost like the the
construction phase of that I mean maybe
I've been reductive well yes and no at
first of all every quest next is not
static at all so cities or it could be
destroyed or move or like be founded by
the players all kinds of different
things so the worlds are constantly
changing and in fact the world's deviate
over time so the deities go into work
each individual world develops its own
personality and what's going on with
what by whatever the players decided
landmark by its own nature is a giant
sandbox where the players can literally
do anything without us guiding them they
come up with science fiction stuff like
there's a guy that's got a fleet that's
sailing around the world there's all
kinds of stuff that's going on the
players determine their own destinies
and we provide them that make
that we use to build EverQuest next so
like the PvP systems the dungeon
mastering stuff for sitting up scenarios
and story arcs all that stuff the AI
editing tools all of that stuff is
coming to landmark so that they can
literally build whatever is in their
imaginations and everybody else that's
blank can experience it and so what how
are you using as a development studio
you are you cherry picking parts that
you liked be it long or a particular
quest or a particular building or is it
more trying to engage with the community
before the game comes out and get them
ready for EverQuest next once it's out
well there are people that play a lot of
people that play landmark that really
are cool with just playing landmark yeah
they don't they're not necessarily
looking forward to every class next but
there are certain percentage of them
that are really fired up about helping
build EverQuest next and so when we
engage with those people we do things
like right now we're doing a dark elf
workshop we gave them all of our concept
are in our art Bible for what we're
doing with dark ales and they're just
riffing on it like they're building all
this crazy stuff and saying when this be
cooler and our art director and our
creative director is working with these
people on a regular basis like every day
we have a live stream where later today
where they're talking back and forth
with the players and we're changing our
art Bible to match what the players have
decided that they want and that is
shaping what north will become so that's
all part of what landmark can do but at
the same time like recently we had a
landmark of landmarks competition and
the winners of that competition those
are those structures that they created
will show up at the player hubs when new
players begin and the first thing a new
player sees is this wonderful amazing
construct that a player made with a
plaque at the bottom with that guy's
name when he wanted and what contest it
was and we do the all these snapshots of
really cool stuff as we go forward so
there's like time slices of the
development of landmark as we go I've
got a bunch of questions for Dave myself
but if you have any app Donnie O'Dwyer
on Twitter or send me a message in the
chasch itani 02 are there and I'll make
sure I send them over to Dave here okay
I've got a question about the I guess
the MMO genre eq has is it you know the
forefather of so much we've seen ya hem
it posts in a post world warcraft world
there have been very few games that have
managed to sort of to really do
something new with the genre or like not
maybe that's a doctor for things like
guild wars but nothing has had that
moments that where tobacco
live and do you think this type of the
amount of personal customization of on
building on your own land of moving the
cities do you think that EverQuest next
like this is the new frontier what I
memos are well clearly we do otherwise
what the hell are we doing seem to be
deep diving in this direction that's
true well I mean like we've run a lot of
theme park MMOs at SOE I mean a lot of
them probably more than anybody else in
the world yeah and we kind understand
that the static theme park worlds that
we have been building well they're not
succeeding anymore they're not there
hasn't been a big hit in that line for a
long time so if you take it as a given
that it's really difficult to succeed
with a model like that you really need
to do something different and if we're
going to do something different well why
not do the stuff that we've always
wanted to do by letting the players
collaborate with us and make a
difference and be dynamic and have the
whole world be destroyable and all of
that stuff that we've been talking about
for the last year since the last instant
we live and and we've been doing it I
mean the world is destructive we're
going to be able to do it to demo the
emergent AI in another month or so we've
got you know the caves go all the way
down to the core of the world all the
stuff we said we were going to do is
happening and it's getting cooler as it
goes so the caves and the oceans you
mentioned before we started that's
that's just been added in as well recess
i right yeah we just last Monday or
sorry this monday we debut the caves
which are these huge underground systems
that were you can go through and explore
them there's occasional earthquakes that
reshuffle all the cavern awesome there's
treasure chest where you can only get
certain items that they're only found
deep down underneath the ground and then
later as we add more combat in danger
those that's what we wear like monsters
start to reside and it becomes dangerous
and creepy and that's if you don't mind
me talking about a little bit the
economy of the game depends upon the
different groups of players wanting to
get together so like you know builders
need like the PDP and the and the
dungeon mastering guys because so that
they have an audience for the pieces
that they're building and these guys
don't necessarily want to build a house
or a hassle so they work with the
builders and the adrenaline seekers that
want to go down into the caves need the
crafters to make the items and stuff
that they use and the crafters need the
adrenaline seekers to find the bits that
they need to make stuff with so you know
it's all this interactivity and that's
what a good MMOs all about and I guess
on the other side of this is as great as
you're handing the two
is over to users and their imagination
can run completely wild perhaps in ways
that you might not necessarily desire
like how do you stop this turning into a
second life for instance where it's that
there are no rules and by virtue of that
there is no tone that sort of exists
throughout the world well I mean
landmark is set up in such a way that it
kind of protects itself well let's just
say that we rely on thin-skinned players
yeah there's a lot of people that will
report things that they don't like
seeing and then RCS system is set up in
such a way that the people that report
accurately go right to the top of the CS
q and I feel like cry wolf a lot they go
to the bottom so that we don't have to
deal with those reports and it's really
easy for us to turn claims invisible and
take care issues like that but really
all we're really worried about is you
know a graphic nudity that sort of thing
sorry I p violations almost everything
else is good to go and so people are
building all these crazy sci-fi and
fantasy and modern build-outs like i
said fleets all kinds of crazy stuff and
now that you can go underwater I pretty
much expect to see see labs and
submarines and a excellence yeah what
other type of stuff I'm interested as to
what are the what other interesting
things have you seen users create over
the past couple of months oh well I mean
the landmarks a landmark competition was
amazing the kind of stuff that they did
but really to me it's the stuff that
people do with those things that's
really intriguing to me like there's a
couple of groups like an angel bay and
late spring Academy groups like we don't
even have guild structures in the game
yet and they're already doing this
online and what they did was they
realized that there were a lot of people
that were kind of bouncing off the game
because they didn't understand how to
use the tools in a cool way okay so they
self organized in order to be able to
teach people and attract new people to
the because they wanted more people like
these games are all about bragging and
what's a better way to brag than to
teach somebody how to do something cool
as though they're doing it naturally and
the fleet that moves around and they do
twitch streams this fleet picks up all
its claims and moves to new locations
and then the boat show up like the
feeder fleet arrives and they do these
twitch streams and then the fleet moves
on to another location stuff like that
is really cool and it's just the tip of
the iceberg for what players can do
later on how many how much of the
audience for EverQuest next and do you
think is guys he and garlic
used to play eq back in the day or like
i say back in the day like it's an old
game like ever greatest husband has been
existed like non-stop until it's all
gone strong yeah so about how many
people's food everywhere like I'm
branded man I'm like I'm not like I run
every question every quest to landmark
and EverQuest next oh I oh yeah so like
that's all I do with my life and these
guys are really good every question a
request to we did an analysis of the
numbers and we figured out that about a
third of the people that play landmark
play every question every quest to so
there are very representative group
inside the game but they're not the
majority because that would that would
be a worry perhaps if you were just
preaching to the choir don't worry that
would be a worry but we're not we're not
experiencing that and when we debuted on
Steam our numbers shot way up and we've
had them in a good old time so there are
lots of people in the chat asking how
it's available at the moment see just
the heaven itself occur Todd closed beta
oh it's closed meadow so you can get it
from us directly from SOE or you can go
to steam and be able to download it from
there and there's different founders
packs that you get into later on when we
go open beta this will be a fully free
to play game cool right now we kind of
want the people that are really
interested in the game to show up to be
engaged a fair enough EverQuest next am
i right in saying that it's also coming
in a PlayStation 4 it has been announced
by our boss yes okay all right landmark
is a purely pc at the moment those are
currently okay currently well I mean I'm
love for you to be on as many platforms
is a candy but we're gonna make the pc
game first and then we'll talk about
other platforms cool okies i wanna i
almost don't want to ask these questions
because what i like about landmark so
much is that that the the creation of it
but i just to get back into some other
like I don't know known quantities with
MMOs you talk a bit about and in
landmark specifically do you guys have
PvP do you have any questing stuff at
the moment or is it all about this sort
of emergence creation well right now it
I mean if you play landmark right now
we're set we're fully satisfying
builders explorers and crafters the next
step is to start bringing in combat and
the first step of combat really is pvp
because if we get that player 2 player
interaction and that fun factor down
adding a ion pathing and stuff to that
is it natural that's pretty easy so one
of these we're going to start talking
about is claim based be
EP where you can actually set up rules
and do cool stuff on your own claim but
we're going to hold back on details on
that for a little bit because to be
honest we got a lot of discussions going
internally we want to make sure we nail
it all down before we start telling
people about I guess if you've got such
a you guys seem to be have a pretty open
design philosophy so I mean we tell them
everything we told them like early on in
alpha we gave me the whole business plan
for what we were going to charge for and
what we weren't gonna char really yeah
everything like we're as open as you can
be like we tell them when their people
are sick on the team so they know that
it features been delayed by a couple of
days blasts like this it's like if we
had a hundred thousand people that live
just down the hall from us yeah and it's
really cool like I've never developed a
game like this I don't know of anybody
that's developed a game like this and
it's crazy because it's open development
in the public light of day and we have
to be entertaining our players all the
time while we're doing it and it's a
song and dance that's stupidly fun to do
I think you're amazing if you're making
a game that is inevitably about
fostering community yeah be able to do
that within the development that South
must be very satisfying and the fact
that we have a game that's based around
creativity means that the people that
are our community are just solidly cool
like they're helping each other they're
giving each other tips investigating
things hell they're doing stuff with the
tools we didn't know you couldn't and
that's just the tip of the iceberg with
the building stuff yeah when we get to
AI editing and these on PvP tools and
all that other stuff we expect to be
floored and as we go back and forth with
the players that's how we'll decide what
EverQuest next final form is yeah we
know what EverQuest next should be but
we also know that the players are going
to teach us a lot about our own game and
we want that to be the best product it
can be so landmark awesome David
Georgeson absolute pleasure meeting you
sir best of luck in landmark I'm
whatever Christ thanks as well I can't
wait to see more of it thanks for your
time as on